next trucking is the first trucker
centric marketplace where we connect
shippers with small trucking companies
with a focus on portray edge ports are
an enormous economic engine billions and
billions of dollars of goods and revenue
related to the activities here so
there's a lot riding on efficiently
picking up and moving those Goods in and
out of the ports and up to now it turns
out that this one piece of this vast
logistics industry that was kind of
overlooked Dre that's the point at which
these giant containers come off of a big
steamship that's just crossed an ocean
and then needs to go on to a truck and
then be moved out to a warehouse or a
distribution facility of some sort
capitalism and operation is what it is I
mean each stage in this is somebody
performing a function that's a
specialized function and then handing it
off to somebody else performing a
specialized function each one with the
profit motive that's the ocean shipper
bringing it across the ocean you've got
the terminal operator unloading it they
then pass it on to an independent
operator trucker they bring it to one of
the two railroads for the rest of it
comes by truck get in for the warehouses
throughout Southern California there it
is managed for the country for the large
retailers who actually own the product
that is moving through all of this
there is no single person or group that
runs all of that it's all separate
companies
[Music]
in 1981 the federal government
deregulated trucking essentially meaning
that it was an open capitalist based
market and the industry evolved from
there because from the drivers
perspective they could pick their own
hours they could make their own rates to
pick and choose who they wanted to work
for when they wanted to work for them
and for the trucking company they could
move more Goods at a cheaper cost it's a
very complicated system that probably
would never have been set up like this
to begin with but it's evolved and
there's all these vested interests that
are willing to change if it's in their
upside profit the industry is really
really backward or comparing to any
other industries there's no technologies
and the drivers primarily conduct their
work could be your phone calls or text
messages emails sometimes even fax
there's no transparency for the shipper
strippers don't know where the Lord is
real time they have to call a
traditional broker to find out any
broker cause a driver and when you have
delays at a port complex you have a
whole association of fees that could go
along with it the more efficiently we
move Goods the cheaper it's going to be
at the end of the day for the cargo
owner which means cheaper goods for the
American consumer it's like dominoes
right the first apiece doesn't fold
correctly and impact the whole supply
chain when you have a finite area like a
marine terminal
you can't just pour more drivers into it
you need to operate more efficiently and
that's why I think technology and data
are really gonna be what helps drive
this industry forward because visibility
and predictability is what's gonna make
us operate more efficiently there's
potentially 15 billion dollars of
drayage revenue in and out of the ports
of LA and Long Beach alone nationwide
there's a 60 billion dollar opportunity
according to next truck so if next
trucking is right this is going to be a
very big opportunity for them and it's
because there has been that inefficiency
in the system
we believe in the future trade will be a
seamless experience that works hand in
hand was the rest of the supply chain if
we cannot do drainage more efficiently
the whole supply chain will collapse and
we want it to be the first one who look
at this problems who can sew this
problem
you